i think your audience needs to know
something
because i i don't talk about it a lot um
every single second every
word i say and every conservative is
saying
on airways but it seems like fox talk
radio
podcasts like yours you trust me you are
going to experience a lot of this
as your popularity is growing by leaps
and bounds you already got
i get i get my share you get your share
and i've seen it
and what people don't know is literally
millions and millions of dollars of
being spent
to record every single word we say
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report quick reminder everyone to
subscribe to our youtube channel and
click that pesky notification bell so
that you see our videos
and joining me today is the host of
hannity on fox news
as well as the host of the sean hannity
radio show
and author of the new book live free or
die
america and the world on the brink sean
hannity finally welcome to the reuben
report
no i well thank you for having me thank
you
also because you have been an incredible
addition to
the tv show we got to get you on radio
more um
part of our we have a regular ensemble
cast you're now a part of that
our audience loves you the feedback's
phenomenal i know how popular this
podcast is
uh you are outspoken iconoclastic uh
a free thinker uh independent
believe in freedom and liberty and free
speech and you're not part of the
canceled culture and
boycott and shut everybody down that you
disagree with and
and frankly isn't it crazy that we
conservatives are those guys that we're
the ones no
i don't want to cancel anybody boycott
anybody or get anyone fired
let people decide let people have
freedom of choice
yeah well i suppose i could just let you
go and say nice things about me but i'll
go back because i actually i got the
book yesterday i read about half of it
so far but i want to start with exactly
what you just said there because you
said it to me on air a couple weeks ago
and i thought it made a really good
point that you get boycotted
all the time you know media matters and
the rest of these guys they're
constantly coming after you
trying to take you out take out your
sponsors etc etc
but you personally never call for a
boycott for any of the guys that are
doing
far worse stuff in my opinion than
you're doing can you just talk a little
bit
about what it's like to just be in that
machine all the time just be in that
atmosphere
of boycotts and the rest of it all the
time i i think your audience
needs to know something because i i
don't talk about it a lot
um every single second
every word i say and every conservative
is saying on airways but it seems like
fox talk radio
podcasts like yours trust me you're
going to experience a lot of this
as your popularity is growing by leaps
and bounds you already got
fee i get i get my share you get your
share i've and i've seen it
and what people don't know is literally
millions and millions of dollars of
being spent
to record every single word we say in
the hopes that we say
one word one phrase one sentence there's
one paragraph
that either that they don't like or
they'll take out of context
or they'll clip so that they could
either
boycott us to make us financially um
not not viable which you know there is a
business aspect to being on the air it's
not cheap to be on the air whether it's
a podcast a radio show or tv show
because they want to silence you i i can
give you my track record
going back to the time that bill maher
now i'll be very frank
i hate bill maher i i don't like his
show i think it's gotten worse
i think he's radical extreme i disagree
with pretty much everything that's come
out of his mouth i've had him on a
as a guest a number of times
but i do respect his iconoclastic
style i do respect that he'll say things
that he knows will upset people
but it was people like myself when abc
was canceling
politically incorrect uh that said no
don't cancel this literally standing up
for him
now we'll never get credit for that i've
never had
or witnessed liberals or liberal groups
now they say they're for free speech
they're pro-choice but they're not
because every time there is any effort
to boycott any conservative voice
libertarian voice or any voice they just
don't like it's always okay
we got to get them fired get them
canceled boycott them so they're
financially they're not viable anymore
and then ultimately what the goal is to
get their voice off the air
every single prominent conservative this
is not
a small effort we're talking about tens
and tens of millions of dollars to do
this
and it's done it's an intimidation
tactic
and it's funny because i can tell you i
give you a long list of people that
for example i had a huge twitter feud
with jimmy kimmel
that went on for a while and i went adam
hart
and i reminded him of all the stupid
things that he said it all started
because he was making fun of melania
trump's accent
when she was reading books to children
i'm like are we really going to pick on
women
and then i brought up all the old videos
of him
uh you know cause karma loan
you know right faith yeah yeah put
putting like
cucumbers in his pants and approaching
women
from from old shows he did and then i
would always hashtag disney because i
always knew disney had no appetite for
uh
controversy not to get him fired but to
send a message
you're gonna be a jackass i can be a
jackass back
now when he really came under fire
recently
and apologized for that older skit as it
relates to carmen alone
uh like jimmy fallon did a year earlier
not once did i even comment on it i
stayed out of it
i had had my fight with him i'm not a
boycotter
i'm not a canceler i actually believe
that
people should have the freedom of choice
people have to choose to
listen to my radio show watch my tv show
and sign up for your podcast which is
enormously popular
it's one of the most popular podcasts
out there now and all credit to you
but you're a target too why is it the
left doesn't stand up for freedom
and liberty and free thought and
expression and and the free open
exchange
of ideas you know i'll say this too
they act like they're so outraged donald
trump
outrages him they wake up donald trump
says this or that they're
outraged it is selective feigned moral
outrage it's not real it is phony
it is it is selective because they want
to
act all outright they're not that
outraged if you're that offended by what
you're hearing on the radio or watching
on tv or choosing to
watch on a podcast if you don't like it
turn the dial
i don't want people turning the dial i
actually
i want to build my audience but i'm not
going to compromise who i am what i want
to say or the values i stand for
because they're going to try to
intimidate me and silence my voice
i'm not going to allow i'm i'm going to
fight to my dying breath
but i'll also fight for their right to
do and say what they want to say
they've lied you know the media in
general they've
99 percent of them have been lying to
the american people from the day that
donald trump and melania trump came down
that escalator of trump tower
you know it has been lies and smears and
slander and besmirchmen and
libel and character assassination it has
been conspiracy theories that
one false conspiracy theory after
another one hoax after another
you want to talk about hypocrisy i'll
give you breathtaking hypocrisy if you
want me to keep going here because
all right well even though i know you
don't talk about this that often as long
as we've sort of done the boycott thing
can you just talk about the personal
side of it because
one of the things that now that i've
done more of the cable news shows
and i've gotten to know some of you guys
you know i think the average person
doesn't really think you guys are human
like there's sort of this feeling like
you guys just
live in that box you live in that box
and they only know you as the
as that personality right they know you
sean hannity on the hannity program
he talks he goes he interviews but can
you talk a little bit about the personal
cost of just dealing with that nonsense
all the time
you know for me personally
whatever switch maybe you're supposed to
have
that you're you're you care about what
you read about yourself
i i i tell it's it's interesting i'll
back up and tell you a
backdoor story to get to your answer is
that
there always be new people i'm i'm like
the old guard at fox i've been there
since
october 96 we went on the air i'm i'm
sort of like
the the veteran on the team right but
there'll always be new people that come
in
work at fox and i always try to be nice
and helpful whatever i can do to help
people
i i'm a believer that it's not a
zero-sum game a rising tide lifts all
boats my success is not predicated on
other people's failure i've never
believed that at all
i i champion and cheer people success
but
inevitably they get to that moment where
they're on the air
and then they get the first negative
article or they get the first attack
and they are broken up and they're in
pieces and i'm like
okay first of all welcome to the big
leagues congratulations yeah
wear it as a badge of honor right you're
making a difference you're being noticed
secondly i say if you want to feel
better about yourself go google my name
because when you do sean hannity
hannitymoron.com
seanhannitysatan.com sean hannity's
lucifer on steroids.com whatever it
happens to be
so whatever switch i'm supposed to have
that gives a flying rip i would say
otherwise
you know but i'll be i'll be i'll i'll
be on my r rated side today
hey this is podcast land you can say
whatever you want man we don't even i
don't give a [ __ ]
there's your answer i don't care the
switch doesn't exist
now on the other hand i have
an 18 year old daughter and a 21 year
old son
now my only concern honestly is for them
i don't even care about like my extended
family or my sisters they know who i am
they know
me and when people make
false allegations or attack you
you know my kids are so used to it that
honestly at this point i don't even go
to them with it
because they usually don't hear about it
my son will hear about it only
if it's on bar stools dad you're on bar
stools today
i'm like okay that means i guess i've
made it right
sign of the times man she did thankfully
they don't care
sometimes you've got i have to explain
to them
and i remind them too that there might
be people
that know that they're
related to me that they're my kids that
may not like me
and you i always warn them the upside
and downside there's a lot of upside for
them
but that for me um i didn't grow up with
famous
parents i grew up with my mom a prison
guard my dad a family
court probation guy and a waiter on the
weekends
so it's very different but it's all
they've known also
they've been they've been at events with
20 plus thousand people in arenas that
i've
i've been hosting so they've seen the
people that
are also invested as i am
in what i love the most which is this
country and
and the things that i believe in and the
passion and the freedom and the liberty
of america and the dream that is america
because i am that dream and uh you know
i could talk more about that later if
you want but
so i don't have the switch i don't care
i care about my kids when they're
impacted by it
everyone else i don't care so you
mentioned a little bit about your
upbringing and uh by the way
don't ever don't ever hit google alert
that says dave rubin
don't put that on your phone don't read
twitter
i can't even i have no access to my
social media accounts
i have to go through an army of people
before i can send out my own tweet
i have no passwords no i see how you now
i see how you have that great hairline
because you're not on twitter that's
clearly the
answer that's clearly the answer uh so a
couple
a couple weeks ago i was on the show
with you with dan bongino
and i mentioned i i was googling
something right beforehand and i saw
that you were born in new york city it
turned out that dan was born in queens
and i was born in brooklyn and and i
mentioned it on air and i thought you
know maybe there really is something
there
that people born in new york for out for
as out of whack
especially as new york city under de
blasio is and and cuomo as governor for
as
out of whack as new york is maybe there
really is something
special about new york can you talk
about that a little bit because you're a
true new york
guy you still live in new york you can
add to that like
bill o'reilly right you can add to that
guy tom
tom lycus was a highly successful host
nationally and
and started and spent a lot of his
career in los angeles
it probably has to do with being very
outspoken
now i i left new york and pursued a
whole other life i was i was out of new
york 16 years
and i started radio you probably weren't
born yet dave uh
1987 was the first time i got behind a
radio microphone
close i was 11 hannity come on what uh
you're what
11. you're 11. okay you look great
you know why because you have a lot
slicker hair than i do and you've got to
be using just for men and i've never
used just for men so
i'm teasing no nothing no nothing no all
natural you got it right here
some people used to write me as your
hair real and i let be pulling it on air
yeah it's real
um but you know i like
i like outspoken people i like people
that are not afraid to express their
views
and honestly if you go through your life
and you
you you care about what people think
about you
and it stifles you and it silences you
and it boxes you
in either i always say
on radio and tv i'm on the air four
hours a day
i'm now this is all extemporaneous our
discussion here today right
and you can't fake it for four hours a
day
people see through bs they see it
and what you hear and what you see is
what you
get radio's more of a warmth heart
medium i have
three hours tv i have an hour it's fast
paced it's a lot of news we're getting a
ton of information in it
and um and i feel like we're doing work
that nobody else in the media is doing
people like yourself and you mentioned
dan bongino help out a lot
you know you've been a phenomenal
addition to the show
so but i don't want to live my life
giving a flying rip
with some idiot keyboard
warrior in their underwear in their
parents basement at 60 years old
cares about me or says about me
anonymously on some social media site
that's why i have no access to any of it
i don't ever read it you just handed us
the clip that's the promo clip i mean
that was taylor taylor made promo clip
right there the guy in his underwear
not me the keyboard warriors that are
psycho oh not you
no not hannity and he's not in his
basement and his underwear is
anonymously typing out i hate hannity
that's not me
oh all right well they'll they'll still
come after you for it
um because the grind of it the fact that
you're doing all those hours
on the radio then you're doing your hour
at night and that you always have to
have something to say
and i know with you that it is authentic
but that the you know we went from
uh you know network news to ultimately
cable news then it was 24 hours and now
in effect
it's every time trump tweets i mean
we're in a five second news cycle now
do you think any of that is is actually
part of the problem
right now sort of why we're all kind of
crazed about politics
i'm for more information not less
information
i could tell you when i first started in
radio i mentioned the light went on
first time believe it was 87 no long no
later than 88
which makes me 32 plus years in radio
it's a long time
and i remember my first professional
radio gig where i actually got some
money
was in huntsville alabama i started in
california and by the way when anyone
starts on radio you're terrible and i
was trying to you know
i guess i wasn't as authentic i was
trying to
there's a great scene in howard stern's
uh private parts right if you've ever
watched that's my life
except i do a different form of radio
right very different but
i know what it's like when you start
radio all right here's the weather
hazy hot humid a chance by late
afternoon thunderstorms
uh right now it's 78 degrees sunny
chance of storms and more of the hits of
the 70s 80s and 90s coming up right here
on www
or whatever right you just want remember
it was it was wnbc
in his case yeah but he shows that
and i did that i mean when i started
you're terrible when you start
that it was interesting because you're
starting in this whole
there's a whole other path that wasn't
open
to somebody like myself but there were
more opportunities there actually
were talk radio stations that hired
young guys
it's sort of like the farm league that
maybe one day some of them might be able
to get to a bigger market
and you know i started i get thrown out
of town in california i deserved it
totally you know awful uh i go to
huntsville alabama
i arrived there in 1990 and
then i worked there two years and i went
to audition uh
in atlanta for two nights i got hired i
spent four wonderful years in the city
of atlanta i'd love to talk about that i
got to
i got to know these civil rights
leaders you know we recently lost john
lewis
i have nothing politically that i agree
with john lewis
except that and the first day in atlanta
i got
a call to my radio show from then mayor
maynard jackson
but i got to know joseph lowry the sclc
they all come on my program the mayor
would come on my program
hosea williams was my favorite guest
ever really
close friend of martin luther king jr
john lewis andy young and i don't think
andy liked me much but
but all these guys i i knew when i got
to know their story and it was one of
great courage and conviction
and and if you look at selma to
montgomery if you look at
fire hoses and dogs and i learned this
lesson
you see the the peaceful protests of
that time
they helped make this a more perfect
union
they put it all on the line here's an
interesting side note to this
you know because we watched the eulogy
with obama
this uh the eulogy obama gave it at the
john lewis
uh remembrance and all the politics that
he brought up which i
found outrageous just it was a political
speech
it was it was awful yeah but he talked
about the john lewis extension of the
voting rights act
and i'm thinking well hang on a second
because the guy that's leading your
ticket
joe biden the ever corrupt ever
forgetful
ever out of it joe biden uh
well joe biden says his mentor and his
dear friend was robert byrd
the former klansmen by the way hillary
said it
bill said it schumer said it pelosi said
it
so the talk so so former president obama
is talking about these historic bills
that john lewis
absolutely along with so many others
bravely fought for and made us a more
perfect union
not perfect we still have a long way to
go but so
and yet they're talking about the act
but
the guy that's running actually
supported
the guy that filibustered that historic
legislation
people don't know and this drives me
nuts every two years every four years
what do they say about republicans it's
every election cycle
republicans are racist sexist misogynist
homophobic xenophobic islamophobic
uh they want dirty air and water a paul
ryan look alike it'll probably be a
donald trump look-alike this year
is gonna take granny in a wheelchair
after she's only eaten dog or cat food
for a year
and throw her over the cliff in the
wheelchair that's every two and four
years
it is atrocious i went through on
hannity this week a history of how this
happens every two and four years
well the civil rights act lyndon johnson
needed and the voting rights act
80 percent republicans 80 percent
republican of the house and senate and
then you have the mentor of their
democratic presidential candidate
praising the guy that filibustered that
bill i mean that's madness to me
that's the guy that when integration was
coming up talked about
uh uh kids and integration of school
as a racial jungle that he was worried
about
what donald trump said this is an actual
quote this is an actual quote so i think
a lot of people
are waking up to this and i think that's
partly because suddenly
well suddenly people can see the clips
online where in the old days you
couldn't really see the clips right
what do you think happened to the
republicans or to the gop
or to conservatives that let this thing
get so
confused that the reality of the history
compared to the way it's it's portrayed
is that purely just a media concoction
or
do the republicans have some blame there
themselves no republicans
generally republicans have gotten weak
i'll give you an example i i said
they're weak they're timid they're
spineless they're visionless
i said that for a long time when
republicans
finally elected when we finally got a
republican president that would repeal
and replace obamacare
where were the republicans that voted 60
some odd times to repeal and replace
they disappeared and they never even had
an alternative in place i had an
alternative
you know either patient power a cato
institute book by
by musgrave and goodman that i've read
years ago or
a doctor that i often put on my show uh
dr josh umber
who who created in wichita kansas
a healthcare cooperative it's only 50
bucks a month 24 7 concierge care
he negotiates directly with
pharmaceutical companies
guess what 50 bucks a month for an adult
10 bucks a month for a child
doctor available 24 7. you walk out with
the medicines at a 90 95
reduced rate you add that with a
catastrophic plan if god forbid you have
a heart attack cancer or a a bad
accident
they were all they weren't ready and
then the senators
actually voted republican senator seven
of them
voted for the exact same bill they had
voted for two years
that they voted on two years prior just
a straight repeal bill
now when it meant something it didn't
mean anything so i'm angry at them for
that now
in terms of republicans allowing this
this false narrative to go forward
i do it every election year dave i i
show the same clips
there's a 1998 missouri radio ad i went
through this this week if you like
republicans
you know a cross is going to burn or the
james bird ad in 2000
that that said it's like my father was
killed all over again
because george bush didn't support hate
crime legislation
uh with this horrific dragging death of
this innocent man
james byrd but george bush bush did
support the death penalty
so he wanted the guy dead you know for
that crime for that
inhumanity that evil and you know or
al gore goes before a predominantly
african-american audience and he's
he changes his tone his pitch his
cadence it's
to me it's like really tries to sound
like he's a preacher in a
a predominantly african-american church
republicans have the wrong
agenda for african-americans they don't
even want to count you in the census
or hillary clinton same thing a
prominent predominantly african-american
audience
i don't feel no ways tired i mean what
is this
she's got hot sauce sean she's got hot
sauce in her bag don't forget that
oh i do remember that yes indeed indeed
um or they're gonna put you all back
in chains so this is
the playbook i told everybody
as i started the year and before i went
on vacation at the end of last year
it's coming they will do it it's the
playbook
dirty air dirty water racist sexist
massage and straight on through that's
what frustrates me about mitt romney
mitt romney the very same people he's
now embracing
are the very same people that said he
was a racist and a sexist and a
misogynist
so it's and it's frustrating the same
people he was running he had he had
binders full of women they said he's a
misogynist now now he's the hero
so is that binders by the way were
women's women's resumes so we could hire
them
okay geez sorry i have a resume
that doesn't make it into the tweets
though you know twitter it's short so
you're gonna yeah you gotta
know i'm awesome i'm in twitter twitter
prison
you're smart man listen but is that what
you just described right there
the the repetitious nature of the way
this goes cyclically every couple years
and the rest of it
is that why you became such a trump guy
more than anything else because
he just was like he clearly saw it it's
very obvious to me as a guy that did not
support trump last time
that it's very very obvious so i look
i'm here in california where my vote is
sort of useless in a certain regard so i
voted for gary johnson who
was a you know he's a nice guy but he
was a terrible candidate but
but that but here we are um that being
said
uh is that it for you was that the thing
that
lit in your brain with trump that it was
like he will fight that
and that is the most evil thing
you're asking great questions so there
are certain points of my
career crossroads points if you will
that i think define
moments that i think maybe the in terms
of the work that
i i have done if it's any good or not
i'll let other people judge it
but when nobody else would vet barack
obama
in 8 2007-8 look into his background of
frank marshall davis and
what is a community organizer what is
the linski who's a linsky
uh what are linsky tactics what's acorn
what is black liberation theology that
he wrote about in his book that so
inspired him the audacity of hope
who was this preacher he sat in the pews
of the 20 plus years
who is bill ayers and bernardine dorn
of the weather underground a domestic
terrorist organization involved in
numerous bombings
that he started his political career in
their home imagine if any republican
that
ever had the history of any of this what
would happen
so as it relates to the president what i
saw and i think what others saw i'm not
a registered republican
i'm a registered conservative like you
we're both very stupid
because you need to get the hell out of
california with the regulation and
taxation
and i'm so stupid i'm in the uh
shift hole of new york
and i ne and with high taxes and
burdensome regular i need to get out of
here
every year my account always says don't
you like fighting from the belly of the
beast because i'm
i'm kind of i don't like getting robbed
it's crazy they're robbing me blind
i i mean and stupidly and i i'm
i'm working on it i'm going to get out
of here but you know what they take in
taxes and how
difficult they make if i told you what i
paid in property taxes your head would
spin around in in circles and you would
projectile vomit
you know green pea soup like uh the
exorcist
it's so it's it's insane but what i i
knew donald trump for 25 years
he would come on my local radio show in
new york city
when i was on at night he would come on
when i was on an afternoon drive
before i was syndicated when i just
started at fox
and i got to know the person the man
now he was a little more left when i met
him
but he was becoming more and more right
and i'll tell you where we really
really connected it was over a
disagreement
nobody's ever no one's gotten this out
of me before so this is new
and the disagreement was my support
which i don't regret
of after 9 11 the
war the war on terror and
but i can see in retrospect in many ways
he was right now we don't
we didn't have the sophisticated ability
of drone strikes as we do today when i
went to baghdad i saw the
my first drone it was not at that point
being used like it is today
you can future wars are going to be
fought like
it's going to be like call of duty and
you're just gonna be
you're gonna have a command center in
tampa florida and people gonna press
buttons
they're looking at a satellite shot or
like a jason bourne movie
boom they're gonna hit it and you'll hit
your target end of the war
so it got complicated as it went on
longer
once you're involved then you know it's
hard to get out i supported the surges
i i like george w bush i know he did the
best he could he was a wartime president
worst terrorist attack in american
history trump's point was
that okay if we're going to fight the
war let's take the oil
make them pay for it that's not a dumb
idea
and he was he was like this is these
long-term protracted conflicts can't
happen
now i would argue in retrospect military
technology
has made that style of warfare it's
completely outdated
we better keep modernizing our military
which donald trump is doing
and if we're going to fight wars we
better win them
i don't want to see kids going door to
door in baghdad again and having their
legs and their arms blown off and
and leaving with these horrific injuries
that they have
and i i do believe these other countries
if we help them
pay us we're going to save you pay i do
believe that the president's right about
that
or obama put in place what what and
biden did the rules of engagement they
put handcuffs on
our military if we're going to go to war
go to war win the war and get the hell
out
and that means that there are going that
you're going to
there's going to be collateral damage if
it's that bad
that our national security and national
interests are at stake and it's that
high
then go fight it win it with
overwhelming force
the reason the president beat back the
caliphate in syria
is because he he took off the handcuffs
that had been put on by biden and obama
and he drove out the caliphate
completely from syria
he used modern technology we knocked out
solamani on a tarmac
you know he was on a commercial flight
most people don't know the solemnity
they followed him through
they could have taken that that
commercial airliner
out of the sky and taken him with it but
we are a country that loves and respects
innocent human life but as soon as he
was on the tarmac
and we had a red dot on him satellite
imaging
we took the shot we took him out we took
out baghdadian associates we took out
the al-qaeda leader in yemen
so that's sort of the future but our our
the beginning of our relationship
started on disagreement
because he would get mad at some of the
things i was saying on air and we talked
privately
and that's how our friendship began but
i also began to notice and
and again i was proud of what i did with
obama i'm proud of
seeing where this was going with donald
trump because i knew him
and i put everything on the line because
i was telling my conservative friends
he's well hannity donated to hillary
hannity he uh said this about this
democrat
hannity legitimate arguments he said he
was pro-choice now he's saying he's
pro-life why do you believe him
because i knew it was true i knew what
was real i knew it was sincere
and the other thing that i knew about
him if he says something he means it and
he's going to follow through on it
he's one of these guys that if you make
a deal with him it is a deal
he'll do his part and he'll deliver to
the best of his ability
and so listen i had a lot of
conservatives furious with me telling me
he doesn't mean it on judges he doesn't
mean it on the wall
he doesn't mean it on tax cuts he's not
going to cut out all the regulation
uh he doesn't mean it on energy he
doesn't mean it on health care he meant
all of it
and he did all of it to the extent that
he possibly could and very successfully
and that is not a story that the
mainstream media will ever tell about
the guy
so i knew i i put if i have
conservative credentials if i have them
whatever
people might say or not i put it on the
line and i told my conservative audience
he will govern as a conservative i've
been proven right
and uh and you know that's a that's a
hey i'm putting it all on the line like
i did with obama
so for a guy that is governing like a
conservative that's that's pretty
obvious at this point one of the things
that we've talked about a couple times
on your show is what's happening in
portland in seattle
in chicago in new york just the crazy
situations of violence and
murder and everything else because of
these progressive policies which by the
way years ago well well before i knew
you when i would flick on your show
you were basically the only guy that was
talking about the
the black on black crime in chicago and
nobody and everyone would what would
they do they would call you racist for
it for even bringing it up you'd say
well 30 black people
died this weekend and they would call
you the racist for it
um but are you are you concerned at all
that that
optics wise when trump then sends in uh
the national guard and we get federal
troops and these things
that this is playing into the hand that
oh well you see he's
he's the authoritarian he's the guy that
wanted to throw all the
all the federal troops into the cities
well when obama said this week that
federal troops
are using tear gas and batons
on peaceful protesters that's not true
and in spite of all the video evidence
of jerry nadler saying
this is a myth he actually said or who
would ever think that a
major party presidential candidate would
say the words
the police or the enemy by what
and supporting defunding the police
i mean joe biden has yet to say a
good thing about the 99 percent of
police men and women that protect and
serve their cities
all of them put their lives on the line
for all of us every single day
and so you you ask a great question
uh donald trump has not sent in the
national guard
unless they request it he's been begging
new york city and chicago and portland
and seattle begging them let us help you
restore law and order and safety and
security
you can't pursue happiness dave rubin
without law and order and a safe
community
if you're a one-year-old shot in a park
in new york dead in a stroller an
eight-year-old
little girl killed in atlanta because
the her mom made a wrong
turn into the chop zone near where the
wendy's that street had been taken over
a new autonomous zone
um and that little girl in the back of
the car
died after getting shot in the head or a
seven-year-old beautiful girl in chicago
died on the fourth of july weekend uh
while at her grandmother's house
you know playing on the fourth of july
or horace lorenzo
anderson uh junior 19 years old and his
father that heart wrenching interview
that i had with him
um it killed me because my my kids are
18 and 21. anyway
so the answer is he's offering now
that's separate and apart from the
we're talking about a hundred troops
that are being sent in to protect
federal property
and federal courthouses that's not only
their job but their obligation
because they were trying to burn them to
the ground uh
they're not there to restore law and
order to the cities
because the mayors refused to do it what
what do
all of these cities we're talking about
new york chicago
portland seattle los angeles the city of
atlanta what do they all have in common
they've all been run by liberal
democrats for decades
now if you believe as i do and i get
into a lot of this in the book which is
over your shoulder
yeah we're going to get there we're
going to get there i promise oh again no
but
but if that actually does this does
color a lot of the stuff in the book
a lot of it it but if you believe in our
founding document our founding document
is our declaration
right some people think it's the
constitution no the founding document
what what does it say i can remember it
unlike you know cookie joe
my favorite clip all these truths to be
self-evident that all men and women
are created oh by the thing
you know the the thing the thing god joe
god every the creator of everything all
right oh
that scared me so but if you believe in
that what what does that line me with
endowed by our creator means that god
rights
for all of us and i believe this my mind
my heart my soul
they come from god they don't come from
men they don't come from government
and that life liberty pursuit
happened how dave reuben you tell me
how do you pursue happiness if you're
living in those cities
and you're not safe in a park or your
grandma's backyard on the fourth of july
or if your mom makes a wrong turn on a
city street
uh or if your son is in the summer of
love zone as mayor durkin said how do
you pursue happiness if you don't have
basic law order safety security how do
you pursue happiness
in all of these cities what is one other
commonality
they all have the worst educational
records of
most cities in the world we pay more per
capita for education
than any other country in the
industrialized world
these cities have this income we have
failed our children
if you look at a ladder i used to be a
contractor right you have the rungs of
the ladder right
okay you take away that education
and i'll give you a little my background
i learned latin
i went to a seminary in high school and
the word education from the latin
derivative at dukeday to bring forth
from within
so if we believe that god gives you
rights
if education is to bring forth from what
is already there from god
talents he gave you well you need safety
security you need education
so okay joe biden is saying that the
government's going to take care of
everything you ever want in your life
he's going to take care of a guaranteed
job at a guaranteed wage and
k through college education and forgive
student loans and government guaranteed
vacations and government guaranteed
healthy food
and you're going to have government
guaranteed health care and you're going
to have a
government guaranteed retirement you
don't have a worry in the world i'll get
to the psychology of that
okay what is the track record in these
liberal cities that have been run by
liberals for decades
which is what joe biden adopting
bolshevik bernie socialism and aoc's new
green deal
and and basil bozo as i call him
o'rourke
and bozo's gun confiscation plan
all right so in these cities they don't
give security or safety
in these cities they fail spectacularly
when it comes to education specific
example
the city of baltimore 13 public high
schools
you want to venture a guess what
percentage in the 13
schools not 13 kids 13 public high
schools
what percentage of kids in those schools
and you don't have to answer it's not a
trick question
i'll i'll ballpark it i'll try just to
see do you believe
are proficient in math and reading
matt let's start with math i mean i i'm
going to guess i'm going to go obviously
crazily low it's
i'm going to get what's like 10
something like that
not one child in 13 public high schools
baltimore spends they're the third
highest per capita for student spending
in the world not one kid in 13 schools
okay here's the latter why don't you
just take a a sledgehammer
rip out all the rungs and and beat out
both sides of it because
you don't have an education so they
don't provide security safety law order
they don't provide education
all right what else has government done
for us if we're going to put all our
hate
we're going to believe joe biden and
bernie's socialist utopia and aoc's new
green deal
okay and they're going to take care of
every single need we have in life
okay how's social security doing dave
rubin
because the last i check you're screwed
i'll probably get something until they
means test it
because it's headed towards bankruptcy
they'll raise the retirement age to
about 30 seconds before you die you'll
be eligible
or they'll means test it you'll have
paid in 50 years and they'll rob you
they'll legally rob you how's medicare
going
that's headed for bankruptcy how did
that obamacare promise thing work out
keep your doctor keep your plan
and save money the average american will
save
2 500 per family per year
well we now know what biden care
obamacare did
we had millions of americans they lost
their doctors
millions lost their plans and we're all
paying on average about 200 percent more
and it's even worse because there's
almost 40 percent of the country
that only has one biden obamacare
exchange opportunity there's only one
choice
in other words there's no choice because
all these companies said we can't
this doesn't work we can't do this so
if you look at all of the promises that
government have made up to this point
and you look at the results they don't
keep any promises
you know i i have a chapter in the book
socialism a history of
of failure well the reason i put
i actually i'm very i did it
purposefully
did a chapter on what makes america
great well you know american
exceptionalism ben it's ben franklin a
republic if you can keep it
well reagan said freedom is but one
generation away from extinction
right we all we all our generations have
to fight for it
you're in the much younger generation i
was graduating you were born in 19 what
76 okay i was graduating grammar school
in 1976 just to give you some
perspective
and uh was the bicentennial at the time
um yeah oh yeah it was and
you know you you look at i lost my trend
of thought here
but i'm just looking at all the things
that they're offering
oh here it is so the i talk about
american what made us great and
successful
that while we're not a perfect nation
we're the country that abused power the
least as my friend barry farber said
after accumulating power i add to that
we have taken all of the power
america's accumulated and what do we do
with it we beat back
the forces of fascism and nazism and
communism and imperial japan
we we protected freedom the history of
socialism is
promises just like the green new deal
just like
obamacare just like you know uh
the educational system and all the
promises made
all these socialist utopias i don't care
if
it's mao and the revolution i don't care
if it's the bolshevik revolution and i
go through great detail in each case
i don't care if it's east germany or
people
they have a wall built and the east
germans want to get the hell out and
they're willing to get
shot or risk getting shot trying to get
over west germany where the life is much
better with freedom
i don't care if it's cuba or venezuela
the promises are all there
the reality the truth of it is for every
bit of security you get
promised you lose your freedom and they
never fulfill the promise
you don't have to have a harvard degree
or be an mit mathematician or engineer
to figure out holy crap
this doesn't add up 94 trillion in 10
years
and you're eliminating oil gas and and
coal
uh and at the same time we're offering
every
everybody everything for free when we
only take in four and a half trillion a
year we don't take in enough money
simple math 52
uh what trillion in ten years for
medicare for all or obamacare on
steroids is joe's pushing
so but but sean as aoc as aoc said you
don't have to do what's factually
correct you have to do what's morally
right
um and especially with a question
yeah by her and the squad
so these promises you know this is the
psychological component i teased a
little bit ago
and it's this ah everybody feels stress
in life
we go about my four grandparents all
came from ireland
i had my ancestry test it was 100
british isle
all ireland right yep and they said
that's rare i did i was
like really and whatever all four of my
grandparents came from two counties in
ireland
my mom and dad grew up broke poor
my dad you mentioned brooklyn i'm
interested where because my dad grew up
in bed-stuy
in in brooklyn really poor flatbush
flatbush flatbush okay i know a lot of i
don't know
i had a few friends in flatbush but a
little before your time
i was incorrigible they were
incorrigible that's why you're
incorrigible
that's that's old-school brooklyn old
school broken big time but my dad grew
up poor
lost his mom complications from his
child birth just a few weeks after he
was born
you know shuffled around the family
member after family mother because his
dad was working just to
you know survive and my mom grew up in
the south bronx
she became a prison guard he became a
family court probation guy and a waiter
on the weekends
and it was a big deal to get out of
bed-stuy in the south bronx and get a 50
by 100
lot where i grew up in franklin square
long island and
and with three older sisters in one
bathroom
that's called hell on earth for me
traumatized me
had to run out to the bushes a lot
because they were offering in there for
hours on end with the makeup or whatever
but but i know that i stand on their
shoulders
they had no guarantees but they
but the the idea of freedom to them
was that they will build a better life
for their children
and their grandchildren i literally know
i stand on the shoulders of my parents
who stand on the shoulders of my
grandparents and those that came before
them
um i never thought when i got behind a
radio microphone in
1987 or eight i forget the exact year
that i would ever have any success i've
always felt that
my radio career is going to end any day
my tv career i'm doing my last show
this is probably my last podcast your
kit you're about to kill my career
this is it hannity you're done um
and i never you know when i worked for
free in radio i never thought i'd get
anywhere with it i just knew i loved it
the light went on and whatever this is
that you see
started flying out of me and i had to
you know eventually
always find your own voice in radio and
tv
your own individuality you usually start
out like
stern and what i described you know
earlier is
all right hello today's weather hazy hot
humid and you know chances were in the
afternoon thunderstorms you know we all
do that stupid radio thing yep
but anyway um but then i just pursued it
because i loved it
not expecting any success my first paid
job was 19 grand a year
in huntsville alabama went to you know
atlanta after that that i started doing
believe it or not i was on fake news cnn
all the time
because they needed somebody who you
know kind of dropped a little a little
controversy into their shows and i used
to go down there all
you call me all right can you come do
the 12 o'clock show can you do the one
o'clock show
um and i went there a lot and that led
to
opportunities in new york which you know
i got very blessed and very fortunate
and when i started at fox
i remember saying to my friend do you
think i think we'll last three years
we'll get three years out of this
well it's now year 25. so but they did
all right
i thank those my parents and
grandparents they made it positive they
took the risk they lived the hard life
my mine's hard too i'm not gonna lie
this is not you know
i'm i'm i'm grinding 24 7.
yeah the the stakes are probably a
little fancier but
you know it's uh it's pretty good well i
don't know the truth i was happy
when i was happy going to tad steakhouse
when i first moved to new york
it's like eight bucks you got a t-bone
steak potato and a vegetable i was like
this is heaven
i will tell you why the paper stays now
does that place still exist i remember
the one in times square to have it
no it just went away the last one went
down how long ago
a year about a year ago i look i i
wasn't it was like two years ago i sent
my assistant go get me a tad steak
just for just because i liked it that
was it
it's a greasy times square steak so well
i love it
i love you just told the story of your
family because you know i go into that
into in my book as well that we
are we all are you know my great
grandparents
fled europe and then my grandfather grew
up one bedroom
six kids his father died when he was two
he was lower middle class
my parents were middle class i'm doing
all right i mean it's it's the beautiful
thing but let's
let's link all of this to your book
because what we've been talking about
here it's sort of all
is bouncing around the book but you and
i share one special thing in common
beyond the new york thing which is that
we do
see the progressive movement as the
greatest threat
to liberty and freedom and and
everything else we've spoken about here
uh for some of my pure youtube people
they probably don't know you used to
host a show
with alan uh combs who was a uh
liberal he was a liberal he's passed on
since but
you were the conservative he was the
liberal and i would say he was more of
an
old-school liberal he wasn't a sort of
crazy banana's lefty
no let me finish i just he was crazy
left
he drove me crazy listen the nicest man
in the world
heart of gold but he he actually
believed that crap
and it drove me crazy but we ended up
getting along
was he really i see it maybe maybe that
maybe is a little bit of just my memory
as a kid but i
he was pretty hardcore we used to try
and reign him in a little bit
yeah so so all right so whether he was
crazy lefty or whatever
i assume you you recognize that there
once were sort of
sane liberals you just kind of disagreed
with them is that fair to say yeah i was
telling joel [ __ ] this and uh i like
from breitbart in an interview i did
with him
i knew they used to be we call them
scoop jackson democrats right or
more modern times but nobody knows what
i'm talking about but
or joel lieberman when joe lieberman
who i happen to be friends with loved
the guy nice human
wonderful human being wonderful family
and
he and i share a passion
you know for israel uh you know our
our closest ally in the middle east the
only the democracy in the region
and he also stood strong against radical
islamic terrorism
which it is a real
threat to the world the reason
the iranians now or you have this new
alliance that might have been
unimaginable five years ago between
the us israel the saudis
jordan the egyptians the emirates
is because they understand you know the
threat of iranian hegemony
and their pursuit of nuclear weapons
that is a that is a
clear and present danger for the world
so something that maybe was unheard of
even five years ago you know this is a
real alliance a real threat that iran
poses
i've been best i've known bb netanyahu
man
that goes back 30 years 25 years like
with with president trump
and i've been to israel a number of
times and uh um
you know i've learned so much history
being there
but there's been no president by the way
that's done more for israel
that's done more for religious freedom
that's done more
for for any of these
pivotal issues than donald j trump best
friend israel ever had has been donald
trump
the best friend christians in america
has ever had been donald trump
the best friend of religious freedom has
been donald trump
as as evidenced by his saying trump so
you're telling me trump's not an
anti-semite he's not a racist he's not a
homophobe i can't believe it sean
that's what they tell me well i read the
same story
that's what they say about us too they
attack us all here's the thing
but that party is so extreme now what
when that old democratic party's gone
when they went against joel lebron i'm
like wow nice guy
he has a different view on foreign
policy and they
defeated him in the primary he ran as an
independent and he won
and you know i think it speaks volumes
there are no moderates i argue in the
democratic party today they don't exist
not not with this bunch that we now have
and that's the danger you know you want
to go bring this
full circle here that is now
the danger of if biden wins
here's what we get his stated policy
he's chosen his economic czar actually
plagiarizes it but he has a long history
of plagiarism
uh bernie sanders radical socialism for
the economy
he's adopted and pledged trillions of
dollars to aoc's green new deal
he's bezo bozo as i said earlier
he's the gunzar then you add pelosi
schumer and
biden you got 125 years of failure i
have a question for everyone that
watches your podcast
can you tell me one thing joe biden has
done for 47 years in the swamp
one thing one thing you can one
accomplishment you can point to
that you could say joe biden made that
happen and we're better off because of
it because i can give you
a you know chapter and verse and a list
as long as you want about what donald
trump accomplished in less than four
years
he got he got his son a pretty good gig
at a gas company in ukraine
that counts as something right zero
experience hunter
quid pro quo joe yes you watch the show
um do you think biden is is going to be
the nominee
like i'm still i've been saying it for
months like
they could just take him out at any
moment or he'll announce that he can't
do it or they'll say it's a medical
thing
or or do you think they're really just
trying to smuggle him in
so that the vp can be in charge or the
party apparatus or whatever else
when have we ever watched a candidate
that gets the party nomination
usually historically and donald trump is
the exception
he he campaigned for the primary one way
he stayed campaigning the same way in
the general he won and he
and then he fulfilled his promises
historically it's been
you go right you go left and
then when the general election comes
after you get the nomination you'll move
to the center
he's so weak this is a sign of real
weakness
right well he had to burning people not
still not supporting him even though he
actually plagiarized their economic
agenda
you know they're still members of the
squad that are not supporting
joe biden um are the democrats capable
of anything
well they dragged the country down the
sewer with three years of
a total set up abuse of power
conspiracy theories and a hoax when we
now know they knew from day one
it was never ever ever any russia
collusion the only collusion was hillary
clinton 30 russian
misinformation dossier that was then
used to
to these fisa applications premeditated
fraud on a court
for the purpose of taking away carter
page's civil liberties constitutional
rights and spying on trump's campaign
his transition team
and deep into his presidency and i hope
we're going to get justice because we
need
justice before the 2020 election and no
need to know exactly what went on in
2016.
do you think they're going to keep
pushing on that because it almost seems
like i've
interviewed i've interviewed rick rinel
a couple of times and we've talked about
this and and he firmly believes
everything that you just said there and
he was the acting
intelligence secretary he did an amazing
job
right but part of me sort of feels like
they're gonna let it go no matter what
because
there's so much crap flying around the
country i mean we've just done an hour
we didn't even talk about coronavirus
for a second
um which by the way people will say to
me reuben you're going on hannity's show
he's such an extremist and corona
and i'm every time i'm on there with you
you're screaming about everyone putting
on a mask at a supermarket and
you know i'm here and i'm like uh with
the masks whatever uh
i i say that for a reason though i mean
if you're interested but
you want us to we can go into that in a
minute you want to finish your other
thing yeah well why don't
why don't we finish up with that but but
the point being that
i sense they're going to sort of let the
stuff that obama's administration did go
because there's just so much other stuff
right now and we can only
as a nation we can kind of only deal
with so many problems at once
that may not be right or just but it
just strikes me as sort of how it is
i think it's downright dangerous it look
because what you're then saying
is is that we have a dual justice system
what you're saying is we don't have
equal justice under the law
what you're saying we would be accepting
is we don't have
equal application of our laws because
based on what we
know now is
they knew hillary violated the espionage
act this is the great hypocrisy of
democrats today it blows my mind
to be a democrat or to be part of the
mob and the media oh you take a sip
finally i've been taking sips all night
go go crazy over there
except exactly now this is this is vodka
man
yeah okay well you could have told me i
would have had a drink with you because
i love
i like tito's that's my favorite vodka
um
so what do you have to be to be a
democrat you have to ignore
hillary clinton's violation of the
espionage act 18
usc 793 it's insane that i have that
tattooed in my brain uh you have to
forget that subpoenaed emails were
deleted and then bleach bit and then the
hammers
but you'll accuse trump you'll be all
out feigning all the outrage over trump
and the mueller report not giving a
final conclusion on obstruction which
the attorney general and rod rosenstein
did
which is there is none they're all
concerned about russia
russia russia russia russia but they
didn't give a rip
about the dirty even the new york times
finally called it
likely russian disinformation dossier
that she paid for with funneled money
through a law firm to
fusion gps hiring christopher steele
now we know that they were setting trump
up for this in august of 2016.
now we know before the first fisa
application
that they will warn that it's not
verified it says at the top of a fisa
weren't
verified it was unverifiable now it's
been debunked
now we know that they were told don't
trust christopher steele he's got a
political agenda hillary paid for it
it's unverified
but they used it anyway and they did it
to spy on a presidential candidate then
transition then team
then then presidency
if we allow that breathtaking hypocrisy
to go because look what they did to
manafort
pre-dawn raid guns in the face of his
wife or roger stone
pre-dawn raid 29 guys in tactical gear
frogmen and cnn cameras tipped off
and i'm like okay jim comey was
there was a referral for him for lying
to congress
where's his pre-dawn rate where's
mccabe's pre-dawn raid
where's the pre-dawn rate on a lot of
these people that i've talked so much
about
and in every single case
if we don't have justice here if they
get away with it
number one we're gonna have a lot more
of it number two
as a country you might as well take your
constitution and take it to your
shredder and and just
shred it or burn it because it's
meaningless because that is what the
rule of law is supposed to be about
i am confident i do believe late august
early september
we are going to there's going to be
major developments
because it's all out there in the open
what we now have
available in the public domain and i
spent over three years
on the show three almost three and a
half years
really working hard with a small
ensemble cast exposing a lot of this
is enough that could lead to convening a
grand jury
indictments and convictions in my view
and in the view of everybody that i know
that knows everything so we better get
to the bottom of it
and just to be clear i wasn't i wasn't
saying we should let it go i was just
saying
that that it sometimes seems that the
news cycle or the national production
deal with so many things at one time all
right so
let's finish up with some coronavirus
stuff because that is one of the things
as i've in the last year as i've done
fox more and especially in the last
couple
years i hate that i talk about mass yeah
well people will say oh you're on fox
but they were misleading everyone about
coronavirus and blah blah meanwhile
there's video of gutfeld i think it's
the earliest that i've seen it on on
k on cable uh i think it's january 28th
gutfeld talking about coronavirus there
were many democratic debates after that
where nobody
might have been january 27th i had
fouchy on
that i mean that's incredible all right
so then there you go we're going to
check that because we we like to factor
and i add them on february 10th again
but there you go i mean the fact that
every time when i've been on your show
to talk about lockdowns or whatever it
may be
you make a point of saying that when
you're in the stores you're wearing a
mask and that you want the people to be
wearing a mask and all that
what do you make of just the general
misinformation and the conflicting
information and fouchy
says this one day the cdc the next day
with this
and now twitter taking this week he just
added goggles that was new
now we might need guns oh right now the
face shield and the goggles yeah
look all i can tell you is my own
experience
and um it's anecdotal
but to me it speaks volumes is i
remember
saturday it was one saturday and within
a period of like 36 hours
they were around i was getting reports
18
000 new cases of corona
just in long island and i'm like i mean
i remember being on the phone and i'm
out there like this i'm like
oh my gosh i mean i i felt the weight of
the world that moment on my
in my mind and my heart i'm like this is
this is bad and then i'm talking to
friends of mine that work in hospitals
where we're we're now at capacity and
we're now
we're in trouble and i remember calling
a lot of people about that at the time
and i was very concerned but all
throughout the middle of the epicenter
of this new york lost
36 000 people we now know why because of
the dopey governor and the dopey mayor
just like the dopey governor of new
jersey and the dopey governor of
pennsylvania
and the same in michigan but
when i would go to my grocery store my
drugstore
locally which i'd go every single week
and
every time i went there i saw the same
cashiers
i saw the same guy stocking the shelves
every single time
remember if the packers stopped packing
and the farmers stopped farming
and the truckers stopped trucking new
york would have starved to death and we
wouldn't have had any ppp
and tens of thousands more at least
would have died
but they worked we didn't shut down
everything but i would see i
actually interviewed this kid he's 19
years old he's named robert
every week i go to the store once or
twice and every time he's there he's
stocking the shelves
you know once or twice the no toilet
paper i don't know why there's always a
run on toilet paper
and paper towels but whatever i'd see
this kid every week
he had his mask on his gloves on
everybody in the store had it
not a single person not one ever
contracted corona
now in the middle of the
biggest shift show
at the height the epicenter i'm using it
anecdotally it works now
why would i wear a mask because what the
government's going to tell me to wear a
mask
i'm not saying anybody mandate anything
i'm saying i
choose to because of what i learned
being in the middle of it at the time i
do it for selfish reasons and i do it
for this reason one reason is
we know one thing that remained the same
and the models were wrong and the
doctors were wrong and the experts were
wrong and the governors were wrong and
tv
pundits were wrong and everybody was
wrong and china lied to the world people
forget that part of it
and so but the one thing that remained
steady and consistent dave was
that older people with underlying
conditions and compromised immune
systems
they were the most vulnerable so that
never changed
all throughout this that's why even
though you have you know
the the second wave that hit florida and
texas you don't have anywhere near the
death rate
it's like this you know actually
i think texas and florida what i read
this week
that combined their deaths you know
for the whole time didn't even match
separately each state just one day in
new york
the difference is that stark because ron
desantis
and governor abbott they protected the
elderly population of their states
so i say it that okay i want to protect
grandma grandpa mom and dad
and my parents and grandparents are long
gone but i don't want to infect anybody
else's grandparents or parents and
i also selfishly if it means i can go to
a baseball game or a football game
and where but i have to wear a mask have
my temperature taken as i walk in
i'm willing to do that because i want
life back to normal and i think we can
do it and do it safely
and but the other thing is it's going to
be very short term
because we're getting closer and closer
therapeutics have improved
two studies now came out the one study
that said hydroxychloric one is awful
they had to retract that study the two
studies that came out
the the ford center there's a a system
in new york a hospital system dr
oz talked about a lot they all they said
just the opposite
taken early with zinc and azithromycin
it dramatically saved lives it had an
impact taken early
president this week talking about
convalescent plasma asking people with
antibodies donate your plasma donate
your blood
i think those are for people that are a
little bit sicker
which would help save again more lives
we
never broke down the sequence of a virus
as fast as we did here
which is six weeks it used to take six
years we could actually be in a
situation where we're now in the final
phase trials
uh moderna astrazeneca fisa
where where we could have within nine
months of vaccine
and this is the worst pandemic since
1918. now
add to that what did president trump do
okay
all these gov nobody was prepared for
anything
but the president mobilized and the
president got
all the ventilators we never ran out of
ventilators all the mass all the gloves
all the ppe
um and build hospitals
then he manned the hospitals provided
all the ppe for the hospitals
then converted hospitals like the javits
center three thousand beds they only use
the thousand or the comfort
of mercy out west and converted it to
covert capability
and those idiot governors in new york
new jersey
um pennsylvania and michigan you know
they're sending people with covenant
into nursing homes and that's where
thousands and thousands and thousands of
innocent people were infected that we
could have saved
you just total incompetence donald trump
will never get credit for two things
the fastest and the
biggest and largest medical mobilization
in the history of mankind and he got it
done wasn't easy
got it done and also operation warp
speed getting us to therapeutics and now
we're on the verge i believe of a
vaccine and the next thing he did is
something that nobody ever gives him
credit for
the first identified case of corona in
the united states was
january 21st this year the travel ban
was put into effect
10 days later the one that biden called
hysterical xenophobia and fear-mongering
the democrats were busy impeaching
donald trump at the time when he put the
travel ban in effect
then subsequent travel bans and the
first quarantine in effect
in over 50 years and nobody that
it is incalculable how many tens of
thousands of americans
likely would have contracted and died
had he not acted that early it would
have been exponentially worse
biden schumer they were just out there
impeaching donald trump
so i give him very high marks i think
it's unfair the way he's been treated do
we do everything perfectly no we didn't
we
nobody knew if you know i like fouchy i
think fauci's dedicated his entire life
to medicine and saving lives his heart
is
is sincere he got it wrong
not a criticism china lied to the world
um the models you know first models were
saying two and a half million dead
americans
and it was sixty thousand and it was
eighty thousand now it's 150 000
you know deaths that we know so far we
have gotten better at the hot spots
we've gotten better at therapeutics
we're on the verge i believe of a
vaccine
mass for me we're anecdotal i'm not
forcing you to wear a mask dave you
don't want to
wear a mask i don't give a fine rip
don't wear a mask but you're not going
to get into a baseball
football game right listen i i wear it
where you have to wear it but i
but if i'm walking my dog and i'm not
near anybody else
i'm not wearing a mask but i i totally
get you and i don't like government
mandating it you know what
i don't now if stores want to have rules
and regulations say if you don't have a
mass we're not going to let you in
i think they have the right to say that
um i agree
and if if stadiums want to say
you don't wear a mask we can't let you
in if you have a high temperature we
can't let you
in it's temporary i'd even tell older
people until we really got this thing
fully under control and i think we're
that close now
just for a short period of time the cdc
uh
in the last two weeks actually put out
that if everybody would volunteer agree
to wear mass for four to eight weeks
it's over we'll wipe it out no more hot
spots
president's been pushing it and social
distancing and all the things we talk
about all the time
but the therapeutics it's going to be
medical it's going to be
freedom and liberty which is at risk in
what 90 whatever days is in play here
so am i talking too much i feel like i'm
just no sh listen man you
you brought it around you brought it
around everything that we talked about
here even though we didn't dive into the
book tremendously everything we talk
about here is exactly what
the book is about because you're trying
to show people that that freedom
is on the precipice of going the wrong
way
that's what the book is about and you
know you said a lot of nice things about
me at the beginning so let me just say
this that we have not
we have never met in person we have
until the 10 seconds we talked before we
started this
we've never even spoke off camera before
but you've become a great a great ally
and friend of mine and and you help me
out with the book by putting me on all
the time
and i hope i've added a little something
to your show and we're going to link to
your book down below so
uh so i thank you sean you've become
part of our ensemble cast you're part of
our team now
and you earned it you i remember the
first time you're on
i i wrote my producer while you were on
by the way a little secret
i can text and do shows at warp speed
while i'm on the air even reading i'm
not i'm not at that level yet
yeah you will be it's it's a it's it's
called hd hd
hd what do you call it
steroids there you go i got it right so
but thank you for being such a good
friend of our program
i you're giving me a lot of time here
thank you
this book is about if we lose this
election
in my view their stated agenda will
destroy
the greatest wealth producing
system ever designed by man
that has advanced the human condition
more than
all other societies ever
combined before that's what's at stake
and if you're going to vote for the
president i hope you vote down ticket
live free or die is about really simple
their policies of false promises will
destroy
the greatest country god gave man
i don't want that to happen with all my
heart
the book is live free or die the link is
right down below and sean when you leave
new york and i leave la
i guess we're going to meet in montana
and uh
the tito's is on me okay bring a lot
because i can drink more than you
that's this has really been tito's the
whole time i just haven't slurred like
joe biden yet
hey listen honestly thank you so much
thanks so much for having me thanks for
being a gracious uh host and a gracious
guest on our show and
uh your book's been phenomenal and did
so well you should be very proud
and i'm very honored to have been on
with you thank you if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about the media instead of non-stop
yelling check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out the full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell